i think i might move to one of these hot
spots though and just how how can i
stockpile penicillin the cell later
because i don't
you're gonna have to speak to someone on
clubhouse the app
is rapidly degenerating and
disintegrating uh into
a real i like literally i every time i
ask someone about clubhouse i'm like
but this guy has money right they're
like that guy
is in a youth hostel like that person is
literally homeless like
and i can't believe i was taken by this
like i'm fully admitting i was taken by
clubhouse
like i'm fully admitting i was egg on my
face
i was completely bamboozled by this app
i saw marc andreessen in one room and i
went
this is where the power players are
every single person i have met from
clubhouse in the real world
or have spoken to from clubhouse is like
a fraud on a level of
of epic proportions and not even a fun
one like not even a tin man
uh fun aluminum siding salesman like
it's just completely
insane i mean it's crazy every time i've
got a notification on my phone
uh since i joined like oh this person's
joining clubhouse you wanna
like help help invite them it's always
been
people who like literally went to jail
for identity theft i used to know
like they just got out i guess
the worst people i've ever met and
they're on my phone for some reason
yeah somebody's writing bad shacks he's
now like
hey what's going on on clubhouse let me
start a room
it was a great idea during the pandemic
and i remember i remember i used to call
ray i'm like this is gonna be
big and he's like i don't know i was
swept up in the mania
of the idea that clubhouse was just
gonna be because i had fifty thousand i
have like fifty thousand followers so i
thought like
um and if we don't if you don't know
what we're talking about here just
google it you [ __ ]
but i had fifty 000 followers and i was
like oh yeah this has got to be big
there's no way this won't be big uh just
because i got on it early it's somewhat
early not that early but i'm like i'll
be able to build
here and the whole app was just really
eric weinstein talking for 23 hours a
day
well you told me there was this new this
new wild west of content
and everyone's like you can do whatever
you want in these rooms that you're in
right and then like i'm in the room with
jake paul and he gets all clammed up
because i mentioned the golden triangle
don't think he was clamped up i think he
had no idea what you were talking about
he was like
get this guy out of here which is fine i
mean i'm not expecting him to like the
golden
triangle something he participated in in
la and he's terrified about what's going
to come out
he had no idea what you're talking about
i've heard jake
jake paul was one of the most
intellectual people on that app though
i mean literally when he explained nfts
to david spade
spade could not even figure out like how
to get on the app he didn't know where
his phone was
and like so jake paul i was explaining
nfts and how kids are like digitally
native to david spade and it was like a
fascinating conversation
well yeah it'll be fair i don't i don't
know if that's the negative of david
spade i feel like the
the younger mind has become more
malleable to [ __ ] now
sure but he explained it with a silver
tongue
like he did it was beautiful why can't
you get it david we're [ __ ] these
people
but you have uh you know
lakeith stanfeld who's a fan of our show
i'm a fan of this
what i'm a fan of i didn't know who he
was last time but i
realized oh i love that guy well well
i'm glad you said that
because he just moderated a clubhouse
room where they were calling jews
satanists and parasites and termites
so i'm glad see sometimes you gotta wait
for me
to fully articulate what i was about to
say
and then he put up on his instagram
which is hilarious he goes hey man
thinking out of the box is always going
to come with a cost
because it's always going to come with a
cost man so the lakeith we feel bad for
him he's a fan of the show but he
moderated
cause some of these clubhouse rooms get
real wild
and then people just put them on youtube
it's not like
by the way what a way to lose your job
like it's
clubhouse is the perfect way to lose
your job oh yeah
it's it's worse than twitter it's like
well you can't even hide yourself you
can't even hide
you can't even claim context because
like it's literally a recording of you
saying something right and so they they
they're moderating these clubhouse rooms
it's just like you wanted to go in
because what was the name of the room
like
you know satanist jews or whatever
because i don't know what time is it
half the time these rooms are
incriminating you're scrolling through
and you go like
tom arnold's in this room like what
it's always someone who's trying to get
something going too right you know
it's always someone who's like coming
back from the half dead
trying to crawl into this space you know
what i mean
you know what i mean it's like pete
ulrich yeah rick moranis sounds off on
cancel
culture you know
freedom of expression guys yes it's like
it's like rick moranis you know says pc
culture
like he re-emerges from the from raising
his children and complaining about pc
culture
um but it was it's weird and then
journalists were just hanging out
in the rooms to get people in trouble
taylor lorenz from the times famously
but there were others too
and then there were just scammers like
life coaches and and people that were
selling
i mean this makes me laugh so hard and
if you buy one of these courses on
clubhouse i just think you deserve
everything you can
but people that were selling
[Laughter]
out them were selling like investment
advice and business strategy
courses on clubhouse
selling like marketing
courses on clubhouse i mean think gary
zee but like
all the levels down like when he just
started when he has nobody
and people are getting really ripped off
on clubhouse they were like life coaches
on clubhouse
this is a problem like everyone wants to
show in college these days and they are
awful institutions
but when you in the absence of like
actual colleges look what you get you
get
this is why you have to have accredited
universities yeah
no you get a life coach from clevis you
know i'm not going to mention her name
but there was a comic
i swear to god we were carolines and she
said to me once
she goes i'm also a life coach which i
found odd
she was unsuccessful completely but
whatever then she told me that her and
her family were being evicted from their
home
and i was just wrestling with all these
ideas in my head of like
just the confidence that she has to then
give other people advice
like that's my whole thing i'm like if
you listen to this show enjoy it
maybe some of it's interesting or
whatever but it i'm not giving you
advice ever on anything i'm like
i'll tell you what i think you should do
but that doesn't mean you should do it
ever
that's because unless you're 21 and
healthy in which case
i suggest you not get vaccinated
tim j dillon on twitter if the media
picked this up this would be horrible
i'm just trying to get attention right
why is everyone still paying attention
to him um
you got your vaccinated fizer me too
yeah i got my second shot you did too
right
yeah i was tired i was lethargic
and tired i didn't get sick or anything
i didn't get sick either i felt weird my
stomach felt weird
okay yeah so i would eat and then my
stomach would feel
weird i don't think i got that but you
know i ate a bunch of pizza
you know just instinctively yeah that's
my body's
defense mechanism here just eat the
whole pizza the person giving you the
shackles now listen
you might get a little sick but here's a
good way to hold it down
go eat some pizza you want to hold this
down
you want to hold the demon down go eat
some pizza right now
i mean when you when you when you think
about
the hilarity of clubhouse now tanking
and the people that run it supposedly it
has a 4 billion
valuation what the [ __ ] yeah
look i mean in a country where like you
know doge and good for doge but i mean
like
all these things are happening like when
you go oh i actually have an app
you you might as well be microsoft now
right yeah
no it functions oh good 4 billion